les anciens marché de saint-denis et
saint-pierre le dix neuvième siècle
marque l'avènement de l'architecturé
métallique en europe lit marché couvert
de saint pierre de saint denis sont de
beaux exemples de ce type d'architecturé
la réunion en 1863 la commune de
saint-denis lance un concours pour
construire son grand marché
le projet de l'ingénieur pathé est
simple une allée centrale dessert 10
allée secondaire où se trouvent les
étals pour mettre à l'abri hommes et
marchandises
il recouvre l'ensemble de toiture
version plus modeste des halles
centrales de paris ce nouveau marché est
livrée en 1866 fabriqués en france
la structure métallique est importé en
pièces détachées puis montez sur place
les nombreux détails architecturaux
comme les consoles ou les chapiteaux des
colonnes atteste d'un réel souci pour la
décoration de ce monument premier
ouvrage en fonte d'art de la colonie
une élégante grilles en fonte et tubes
de faire de style néoclassique ferme le
marché côté rue ce principe constructif
et repris une dizaine d'années plus tard
à saint pierre lors de la construction
du marché central
cette halle de 13 mètres de haut sur 36
de diamètre possède un plan dodécagonale
forme rare dans l'architecturé
métallique les extrémités de la toiture
sont supportés par des colonnes
regroupés par trois
ces deux marchés ont aujourd'hui perdu
leur vocation initiale pour devenir des
espaces touristiques
inspiré du modèle des halles construite
sous le second empire en métropole ils
sont protégés au titre des monuments
historiques depuis la fin des années